did you talk to your mom about it yeah
well my mom uh yeah so I was like at
like about 37 I was like huh something's
going you know something doesn't feel
right and um my mom was like I don't
know and so I went to the doctor and
they were like you're you're technically
in param menopause I didn't have like
any of these symptoms I just something
was just felt a little off and it wasn't
until like mid 40s I was like Mom you
have to give me something and she was
like okay
she's like yeah my hair fell out in
chunks uh she was like she's like all
this she's like you can't leave the
house without a you got to do a you got
to do a swoop you got to just check that
there's not like the billy goat gruff
you know having grown overnight all of
these things it's like no one talks
about it and they'd rather just say that
you're crazy or you're bitter or you're
a bee um and you're like I'm I'm a human
being and something is going on and we
need to all be very cognizant about that
and compassionate with ourselves and
other people